st patrick's day is on thursday and in
chicago that means it's time to dye the
river green lately as the tradition
began when a plumber i didn't know this
a plumber suggested using a special dye
that's normally used to detect building
leaks the river keeps its green color
for about one to three days after st
patrick's day can't do that in lake mead
though and freak everybody out i mean
that's really bright green
neon used to seeing that like every year
they do that there this is where brian
comes in handy to fills us in on that
chicago
style but hey a great day today too with
temperatures it felt real nice it was
really beautiful you guys were able to
get out this morning a little walk
listen the dogs demanded yes
right they've got a routine and you know
what they can do that tomorrow too good
this week there are some changes but i
still think we're not going to have a
huge cooldown wait to see that what
happens towards the end of the week
though that's coming up meanwhile live
look outside this time our camera
looking down at the las vegas strip this
is our malaska corporate camera notice
the winds are now lighter than earlier
today skies have cleared up after clouds
we had just a few hours back 69 degrees
our official high for the day today
after 70s yesterday we've cooled things
off just a little bit 52 overnight for
the low still felt nice 71 is where we
should be so we were near average
yesterday today just a couple days below
the record on the state of course 89
that was set back in 2007. tomorrow
we're going to peak about more than 10
degrees warmer than that 69 degrees so
we're going to see some 80s tomorrow 65
for sky canyon right now in centennial
hills same for you 69 for spring valley
74 north las vegas 73 for whitney ranch
71 henderson inspirada included 68
anthem and 68 for mountains edge roads
ranch and mountain and i should say
spanish trails 67 for southern highlands
if your neighborhood was not mentioned
don't worry i got you covered we'll
always switch up our neighborhoods every
uh every weather cast 67 indian springs
83 death valley 75 for loftland you'll
be near 90 degrees tomorrow death valley
as our temperatures shoot way up there
satellite and radar composite we want to
show you the jet stream first we still
have this big ridge up and over us
that's why the temperatures are warmer
going to be warmer tomorrow but we'll
watch those clouds and that system
approach and mainly to the north that's
going to be on that wednesday thursday
time frame look at this so you'll see
clouds tomorrow develop later on in the
afternoon and evening
and then breezy winds wednesday breezy
winds to gusty winds on thursday that's
st patrick's day still staying dry
though we get that little reprieve a
little break before the next one dies
and look at this on saturday more wind
and then look at this chances for
showers slight chance on sunday along
with more wind as well
but it looks like our temperatures will
drop with that one we'll show you that
coming up wind forecast for tomorrow
we'll pick up those winds just a little
bit around the region not too bad
wednesday like we said will be those
breezy winds returning the region and
also on thursday too specifically we
think later on a day so a lot of you be
out about unfortunately for saint
patrick's day we could have some wind
around 50 degrees overnight clear and
cool look for lighter winds tomorrow 81
degrees warmer light breezes look at
this our first 80s since november highs
tomorrow closer to 80 for a lot of you
from green valley to spring valley look
at that 77 for summerlin 80 for north
las vegas 83 green valley outside of
town will be 78 for prompt and 86 for
death valley for tomorrow here's your
eight day forecast now so 81 tomorrow we
cool things off even cooler for saint
patrick's day
and then the weekend oh yeah there's
those chances for showers and happens to
be on the first day of spring that's how
that kind of goes that kind of goes with
you what do they say
oh that's april showers
turn to make flowers
yes we were at the nc2 aids with lon
krueger in chicago when it was green oh
that's when they went to the sweet 16. i
remember that
and speaking of the madness so it
happened